we've got a bit of breaking news to
bring you which is on the former team
sky and british cycling team dr
richard freeman he has been found to
have ordered testosterone to the
national velodrome in may 2011
knowing or believing it was to be given
to an unnamed rider our sports
correspondent martha kellner joins me
now martha
uh pretty significant this
significant it's a bombshell finding in
many ways this was a hearing
by the medical practitioners tribunal
service into the fitness to practice
of dr richard freeman now just to give
you an idea of who richard freeman
is he's the former medical um or head of
medical
to both british cycling and team sky he
was in that role at the time of british
cycling and teams
what was formerly team sky's greatest
success as a time
when bradley wiggins became the first
british tour de france champion
in 2012 at a time when british cycling
soared
to the top of the cycling world this was
one of the greatest teams in british
sporting history
and now they have this huge stain over
their successors
and that is because dr richard freeman
just in the last few minutes
and has been proven by that medical
practitioners tribunal
service hearing to have ordered
testosterone
to the national cycling center in may 2
2011 knowing or believing that that
substance
was to be administered to an unnamed
rider for performance enhancing
benefits now this has been an incredibly
protracted hearing it's lasted
over two years but now we have something
approaching a conclusion
and it's not the conclusion that british
cycling or what was formerly team sky
would have wanted it throws up huge
questions
um for the team principles sir dave
brailsford
for the organization british cycling and
namely
throws up the question who was this
unnamed rider
that the testosterone was ordered for
and we've not
heard that rider mentioned at all during
this medical practitioners
tribunal service um that it was already
hugely
damaging dr richard freeman had already
admitted
18 of 22 charges leveled against him
they include that he ordered that ban
substance that he treated staff without
access to their medical history multiple
failures around
keeping and losing records and also
um that he admitted misleading
investigators and there's been
some sensational testimony over the past
two years
we heard richard freeman admitting that
he destroyed a laptop with a hammer
he said to avoid indian hackers
accessing
the data we heard he'd lost another
laptop
but he's always denied this principal
charge
um of ordering the testosterone knowing
that it was knowing or believing it was
to be given
to an unnamed rider and a sensational
bit of testimony where he said
and that he'd ordered the testosterone
to treat the erectile dysfunction of
shane sutton
a man which was then that who was then
the head coach
of team sky who went on to become the
technical director of british cycling
shane sutton said that wasn't true and
that he had
no problems with performance in that
regard
and but this really is the most
sensational the most
damaging twist and turn yet in this saga
of british cycling
and team sky and it's certainly not the
end it throws up plenty of questions
also next week we'll find what um dr
richard freeman's punishment will be for
this
whether he'll be struck off um by the
general medical council
there are also two uk anti-doping
charges
leveled against him it's not something
that's going away
quickly for either british cycling or
the organization that was formerly team
sky
all right martha thanks for that